so Fox News Alert as we continue  reporting tonight from Hanoi Vietnam  Jorge Ramos six other Univision staffers  detained at the presidential palace in  Venezuela this allegedly occurred after  an interview with the Venezuelan  dictator Nicolas Maduro  according to reports Maduro didn't like  the line of questioning so he ended the  interview confiscated the equipment and  had Ramos along with his colleagues  arrested we do have an update thankfully  thankfully three hours later the group  was released we'll continue to monitor  this disturbing story but I got to tell  you you know what I don't agree with  Jorge on a lot of issues he's an  American